if anything ever happens to me please
note that the 31 terabytes of files I
have are located on hard drives in my
condo near 88th Street and Collins
Avenue just north of Miami Beach now
that's June 8th
2021 right I went and looked it up on
Twitter there is no tweet with him
saying that so now go to the USA Today
story go back and click on that story
says fact check no evidence John McAfee
ever owned unit and partially collapsed
Florida condo which who cares whether he
owned it or rented it I'm not worried
about that what I'm worried about is did
he ever tweet that out the claims I'm
actually on the union impartial collapse
the condominium building of Florida
conspiracy theories are attempting to
connect the death of antivirus
entrepreneur John McPhee to Florida
high-rise building that partial
collapsed on June 24th McAfee Foundation
execution he was 75 as the next
condominiums in Surfside Florida
collapsed resulting in at least four
deaths and at least 150 people missing
the two events are unrelated but social
media users are there's a nefarious
connection actually own the unit at the
building that collapsed the address of
building 877 Collins Avenue South reads
a text message so that leads to AP doing
a story on it Associated Press doing a
story to respond to this if AP does a
story on this which let me see which one
it is it's page four at the bottom
here's what AP says claim the late John
McAfee the Creator John Mack the
antivirus software only unit in the
condo building partial collapse Thursday
outside was located inside that's a
claim a peace assessment false McAfee
was found dead in his jail cell near
Barcelona on Wednesday didn't own the
property at the beachfront Champlain
Tower soft condo in Florida according to
the associate press review of public
records an image of the tweet in which
McAfee claims to own such a property is
fabricated at the close of a week that
includes a prison death of an eccentric
security software Pioneer in the
collapse of a 12-story Oceanfront
condominium Tower near Miami social
media users hatched false conspiracy
theories that bound due to unrelated
events together so and then they found
out that there's a they found out in no
in his pocket and his jail cell yeah
that read
what did he read it said the uh uh uh
there was a note in it you know which
one I'm talking about where you know and
his suicidala Epstein yeah so apparently
they found a note and his wife said
there's no way in the world my husband
would commit suicide his last words were
I love you babe I'll talk to you later
so she's like there's no way this
happens so Pat there's that word again
that we're starting to touch on a little
bit more and more and more conspiracy
theories yeah we're starting to touch on
this a little bit more and something
tells me with this guy McAfee
eccentric dude and all this stuff you
interviewed the guy I mean we spent an
hour talking about this guy let's not
watch the interview the interview in the
last few days has taken off of course
being everywhere everyone's messaging us
what was your thoughts about meeting
this guy look if the Tweet is not up
there you know June of a 08 June of June
8th of this year
easily you can make a fake tweet and put
it out there right now some people are
saying well what if somebody on Twitter
went and deleted it I don't know about
that if it did there'd be plenty of
people with screenshots who had it
because to say you know then there's
some people are there saying that 31
terabytes you should have seen what's in
it because if that reveals itself then
Kai said something very interesting
yesterday saying look if if McAfee is
who I think it is and there's really a
lot of credibility behind what was in
that 31 terabytes do you really think he
would only have one copy of it in one
place no no one the way he would be he'd
probably have five ten of them and would
have him tell everybody where it is
I don't know if you would tell everybody
where it is the point is he had some
information that people didn't want to
have seen what that is in there some of
us will know some of us will never know
some of us are never going to know what
was in Hillary Clinton's Clinton's
emails that was you know some of us are
not going to know what was in the
Biden's uh laptop because he had FBI
doesn't want to investigate it but
there's definitely a little bit of
thought of what was really in that 31
terabytes that this guy had I'd be so
curious to know what was in it and I'm
willing to bet there are millions of
others that want to know was it just the
picture it's a bunch of uh you know
random crazy files that he had or is
there anything there that the world
would want to know about and if it's yes
maybe there is somebody who's a hacker
trying to really figure out what was in
there there's plenty of professional
hackers today that could find a lot of
different things maybe someone's working
on something right now let me tell you
this isn't the end of the John McAfee
conspiracy theories that are going to
run rampant I don't think there's going
to be a lot more uh I heard this I saw
this but just to be clear uh there's no
um credibility to this story no no no
the Tweet is not out there Snopes
actually
um my son Dan just told us Snopes we
looked up Snopes as well I don't even
look at Snopes because Snopes to me also
has made a lot of mistakes themselves of
saying it's false but it was true if a
piece coming out and saying something
about it AP is typically you know they
got not the I mean look we're a customer
of them we like doing business with ap
but if ap's saying something about it
ap's not even saying the only thing that
AP said is the fact that he didn't own
it so they want to look at the record
but they're not saying that that's a
false claim they're just saying
conspiracy theories so who knows what's
going to come I can tell you like you
said next week two week three weeks I'm
sure there's gonna be more stuff that's
going to come out so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]